pas de bol c'est un mec il est dans les
toilettes d'un troquet et puis situe au
moment où tire la chasse d'eau il aa les
terres du mans et qui arrive cependant
le qui tire il est entier qui part dans
les chiottes ivoire le patron guy
carrier monde entier les parties
lâchaient seuil est fouillé mais il est
parti dans l'hymne dans les chiottes
patron m'a dit que témoin là je peux pas
faire grand chose pour vous si ce n'est
vous donner la clé un qui ouvre le
canada avec la trappe qui donne sur la
fosse septique là le mec le veut partir
il a créé des sens ils ouvrent ils
ouvrent la trappe je te raconte même pas
le taux fixe mais fouillaient des deux
bras jusqu ici il faut y trouvons rien
mais un quart d'heure après il remonte
le patron et dire alors mahdia non et
j'ai pas trouvé et le battre on remarque
qu'elle a un petit peu de merde pourquoi
de la bouche elle est dégueulasse
produit dit mehdi musée vu faisait un
petit primaire de quoi la magie ouais
parce que au début j'en avais trouvés
mais c'était pas le mien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça fait une belle sélection de cadeaux
on est parti alors vas-y vas-y donc
c'est une bonne femme qui arrive dans un
magasin ou en vendée le téléphone est
assez joli la quarantaine elle regarde
le prix des nouveaux iphone puis elle
voit des prix de fous kw à 12 cents 0,13
cent euros
elle s'est dite en pis c'est pas c'est
pas pour moi j'ai pas assez les romans
elle va repartir entre un mec un peu
étrange
il fait bon jour le fondeur fait que
c'est quand même un 1300 euros quoi bon
c'est pas grave je vous donne ses 1300
euros de licences et la fille doit
partir en leur disant que tel moi je
bosse toute ma journée je serai pas
maintenant on offrira ça ça mais les
rejets je vais essayer de les piquer si
le gars dans une petite rue un peu plus
loin et puis senti un peu moins de monde
il fait plus sombre le fais pas tu tu ne
donnes tout téléphone je vais te propose
quelque chose je fais un petit bisou et
tu me donnes ton téléphone
écoutez je te montre assez d'accord
cette montre un singe et tu me donnes
ton téléphone
c'est quoi je vais bien je suis une
petite pipe fait petites pépées d'accord
elle ouvre la moyenne
elle commence pour lui mais pas tous les
jours donc après trois secondes
téléphone 06 83
oui
alors ce soir non toutes mes blagues
implique des noms propres des
personnalités détient bien j'avais que
les blagues tple jean luc mélenchon
rentre d'un meeting
ces peoples les amis ça oui c'est paul
jean luc mélenchon qui le connaît il est
connu au terme d'un meeting
il tomba en panne de voiture évidemment
chez l'hiver il fait froid il flotte et
c'est dans une cuvette le portable ne
passe pas il a comme un con et l'eau le
capot il y connaît rien au bout d'une
heure et rigolote et il attend 3 bagnole
qui passe il fait du stop est arrivée
une mercedes à 150 mille euros qui
souhaite qu'ils s'arrêtent et à
l'intérieur il ya un type avec un
costume à cigares mélenchon lui dit
bonjour vous allez sur paru mcgee je
vais sur paris vous pour vous pourriez
me déposer des oui mais avant je
voudrais vous poser une question
vous êtes plutôt de gauche ou de droite
jean luc mélenchon a dit vous me
reconnaissez pas je suis jean luc
mélenchon c'est moi qui ai fait les
insoumis je suis je suis pas à gauche je
suis à la gauche de la gauche le mec il
est tombé pour ta gueule idema un jeu
debout qui le prend dans les yeux
restent comme un con la pluie redouble
il est là il attend une heure arrive une
rolls étant le pousse la rolls s'arrête
il ya une baronne à l'arrière gauche au
surf bonjour vous allez sur paris oui
nous allons son pari vous pourriez me
jeter sur paris nestor posez lui la
question de confiance et le chauffeur
d'une aberration vous êtes plutôt de
droite ou de gauche
la mélenchon il sent le sapin est bon
pour lui il peut pas se renier y arrive
pas il fait bon je suis de gauche
papy boom ou manon elle démarre sur un
jeu de goût dans la gueule et entend un
bruit assourdissant et au détour d'un
virage arrivent à toute allure une
ferrari rutilantes et il tend le pousse
timidement il y croit pas une seconde et
la ferrari s'arrête et là à l'intérieur
une si un canon une beauté un décolleté
une splendeur et dit vous allez merci de
vous arrêter vous vous vous remonter sur
paris que oui je remonte chant paraît
tout à fait c'est vous pourriez avait
déposé ça dépend vous êtes plutôt de
droite ou de gauche
hélas mélenchon il sent que c'est le
dernier métro il fait je suis je suis de
droite un en marche en marche
je suis totalement de droite dans ce cas
monter là il retient sûrement tôt ils
mentent
et là il fait chaud dans la voiture
et un plessis achats des ya des morceaux
sublime et jeter un oeil boîte à la pac
soutien gorge à chappaqua passe la
vitesse il aperçoit sa culotte
elle lui dit ça va mais je dis oui c'est
quand même je pensais c'est marrant la
politique ça fait pas dix minutes que je
suis ma chronique j'ai déjà envie de
baiser quelqu'un je connais people abbas
el fassi racheter des people carla bruni
elle discute avec isabelle balkany
j'ai de la chance jamar et on aura dit
adieu tu vois j'ai marié en taule
[Applaudissements]